le risque d'inflation en france de jeudi
cet épisode est celle il n'y a ce soir
pas de circulation du virus sur le
territoire national de france une
nouvelle étape de l'épidémie et francis
ce jour à 15h selon santé publique
france nous avons 1412 cas confirmés en
france un membre du gouvernement
contaminé franck riester le ministre de
la culture est confiné à domicile son
entourage le dit en forme
[Musique]
le lundi 30 décembre
en regardant les mails je trouve un avis
comme quoi dans la ville de wuhan depuis
la mi-décembre une dizaine de patients
ont été hospitalisés pour pneumonie dit
atypique peut-être virale dont les
remettons tout il se languit les rangers
qui ont été
hewson
suzanne dit le croate olic india on
attend d'avoir une souche à un moment
donné pour pouvant l'expertisé ce que
l'on sait c'est que c'est un virus
respiratoires qui fait partie d'un des
cours d'un virus ce virus semble très
proche du strass mais beaucoup moins
sévère pour l'instant le risque d'échec
en france de lundi
cet épisode est faible d'autant qu'il
existe des lignes aériennes directes
contre la ville en france direction tout
de suite la chine face à l'épidémie du
coronavirus des autorités prennent des
mesures drastiques la vie où est apparu
le virus est désormais placé en
quarantaine
savannah une file à feu et à nîmes et
messieurs j'ai été informé hier soir du
décès du patient de 80 ans qui était
hospitalisée à l'hôpital bichat depuis
le 25 janvier dernier et qui était
atteint d'une infection pulmonaire par
le coronavirus il s'agit là du premier
décès par le coroner virus en dehors de
l'asie donc le premier décès en europe
aujourd'hui la france et l'europe
d'ailleurs en général arrive à maîtriser
par des mesures sanitaires drastiques à
la mise en quarantaine
on nous freinons absolument par tous les
moyens à l'entrée du virus sur le
territoire mais aussi pour cela que nous
n'avons pas d'autre qu'à constater
aujourd'hui
donc oui aucun nouveau cas aucune
suspicion nouveaux cas soyons clairs sur
le sol français à moi j'ai été
extrêmement clairs je serai transparent
la matière le coronavirus est désormais
bien présent en europe l'épidémie touche
de plein fouet l'italie où le nombre de
malades a explosé en quelques jours
passant de 6 à plus de 150
trois personnes sont décédées et le pays
tente par tous les moyens de contenir le
virus
onze villes ont été placées en
quarantaine dans la région de milan et
le manteau toutes les personnes et les
coloniaux kwon do no no no no no no
challenger à perdre mais l'échiné au
père lâche paysage sur la cuisine casa
das que le tabac télévision- est un
homme de 60 ans est mort il était
enseignant dans l'oise il n'avait pas
voyagé récemment dans les zones à risque
que ce soit en italie ou en chine
j'invite à crépy en valois avec ma femme
et mes enfants
on habite ici depuis deux ans on
travaille sur paris et saint-denis et
donc on a appris il ya quelques jours le
décès
d'un professeur de technologie au
collège de crépy en valois
tu sais pas trop comment réagir s'il
faut s'inquiéter pas s'inquiéter
en france une nouvelle étape de
l'épidémie est franchi et nous passons
désormais au stade 2 c'est à dire que le
virus circule sur notre territoire et
nous devons freiner sa diffusion toute
personne qui tousse doit porter un
masque
c'est absolument indispensable les
personnes qui ne pousse pas n'ont pas
besoin de porter un masque
il ne faut pas gaspiller les masques
inutilement le virus est présent dans
certains territoires
il circule mais il n'est pas présent
partout sur le territoire
je rappelle notre stratégie au stade 2
j'appelle tous les français à respecter
et appliquer les gestes barrières que
nous diffusions depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines
lavez vous les mains très régulièrement
tous et dans votre coude et non dans
votre main ce sont les petits gestes qui
participent à la plus grande protection
et qui nous permettront de ralentir
efficacement la propagation du virus
[Musique]
les juges on est juste à oggi et de
laisser la casse il faut tourner sur des
lits taya et nostru manifestement les
deux semaines il expose sa baie oggi
piqué my own you know du phare est la
propre art ce jour à 15h selon santé
publique france nous avons 1412 cas
confirmés soit 286 de plus qu' air
france un membre du gouvernement
contaminé franck riester le ministre de
la culture est confiné à domicile son
entourage le dit en forme
notez que deux conseils des ministres
ont eu lieu au cours des quinze derniers
jours
la question se pose désormais est ce
qu'un autre membre du gouvernement
pourraient avoir contracté le virus
[Musique]